enfants construisant des châteaux dans le sable dans
ma ville enfants la peste ce soir maintenant
notre claviériste essaie de se
noyer je joue des claviers
au Hartford ou est Frank
comment décrire Frank surtout il semble
amical bien que parfois un peu
intense heureusement nous avons un mot sûr
pour  quand les choses deviennent trop intenses
chinchilla la tête qui ne l'enlève
jamais tu penses que c'est bizarre toutes les phases sont
bizarres aussi
Je m'installe dans ma nouvelle vie et
j'apprends progressivement à connaître les autres
membres du groupe Frank trouve l'inspiration dans
tout Je trouve cela inspirant
si je  Je dois grandir en tant qu'artiste, je dois voir
comme il voit